well let's get more reaction to the
latest employment figures released this
morning joining me now is Shadow
exchequer secretary to the treasury of
Bennett upon asari very good morning to
you thank you for joining us uh to start
with your reaction to these figures this
morning and what would labor do if they
were in power
um good morning Sally I want to say
thank you for having me on your show
um the figures that we're seeing at the
moment shows that um things are still
difficult for people up and down the
country where households are you know
going to be hit by another energy price
going up
um so what labor you know labor
completely understands that people are
facing the pinch right now and so we've
we've been calling for for some time now
a one-off winful tax
um which will go towards energy Giants
who are making huge profits during this
this particular period
um and people really need that kind of
support right now
um particularly as we know that the
energy price cap is going to go up in
April
um another thing that we we've been
talking about is having a proper plan
which we haven't seen for 13 years under
this conservative government in terms of
making sure that people are properly
supported because as you've just shown
figures show that you know things are
one of the worst in terms of where
things have been for individuals up and
down the country and we're seeing
constantly a sticking pasta being put
forward by the government
um we have plans to look at how by 2030
homes are insulated about 90 million
homes are properly insulated I know
through my casework and I know through
speaking to colleagues as well that is
the biggest thing that is that people
really need right now which is more
better energy security as well those are
obviously um those are long-term Visions
what would you do about the more
pressing issues of strikes and
Industrial action the ons figures this
morning revealing the eye watering
impacts of days lost to strike action
last year what would labor do about that
how would you get people back to work
and do a deal with the unions I think
the first thing we need to look at is
why are these strikes happening in why
has the government failed to get around
the table to have a conversation
um with those individuals those members
to establish what is going on
um I just feel that you know the strikes
are happening the strikes are happening
because people aren't getting the pay
Rises that they want would they get paid
would they get those pay Rises under
labor so just to be um to be very clear
the reason that the a lot of this is
happening is because the government
isn't sitting around the table to come
to a solution if they sat around the
table like labor would do if we were in
government I do not believe that this
would happen you know we're seeing the
data that this has happened under a
conservative government you didn't see
stuff like this happen when labor was in
government and so what I'll do and what
labor will do when we're on government
if we're on government is to sit around
the table to look at the issues but also
as well as that as you were talking
about the plans that I've helpful with
the labor are talking about those
long-term plans that we have put in
place are things that are going to help
make things a lot easier for individuals
and if the government had listened to us
particularly about you know implementing
a rental tax I honestly do not think
that we'll be in this situation that we
are in right now where we are seeing
people
um having to make difficult decisions
about going on strike because they are
struggling
okay
um let's just move on if if I may uh
Beno there's a quite a few things I'd
like to get through so three and four
councils are set to increase their
council tax by a maximum of five percent
uh from April uh that's gonna you know
cost households significantly more each
year households are already really
struggling what would labor do about
that
I think the the reality is why why are
councils in this situation I think that
unfortunately councils are having to
make really difficult decisions to be
able to keep afloat they're having to
take on the work that the government
really should be delivering in terms of
making sure that our economy is growing
making sure that people are able to
um prosper in the right and Fair Way
um and unfortunately what we've seen
with this conservative government who
have been in power for 13 years is that
we've seen money being lost to fraud
we've seen irresponsible decisions being
made and that is now being
um falling onto councils where they're
having to make difficult decisions
um if we wouldn't be in this situation
if the government has had acted
responsibly if I'm going to be honest
um I think it's a sad situation that
we're in where councils are now having
to make a difficult situation but I
think we really shouldn't differ Flats
away from outwear in this situation in
the first place okay I'd like to just
move on if I may to a more international
issues not at least the surveillance
concerns uh regarding China what would
labor do about this perceived threat now
from China with these balloons flying
around various air spaces
um I mean the threat is really um quite
really concerning
um I mean the advice that we will be
taking is to look at how we can make
sure that the threat isn't as severe
um which will be making sure that um
particularly how the UK is not impacted
in a negative way
um we feel very important that you know
we make we feel it's really important
that we make sure that the UK is
protected in a way that we're not
affected in such a negative way and so
that's something that we'll be looking
into and making sure that this could be
reviewed
would labor designate China a threat
formally and would you increase the
defense spending given the current
climate
I think it's difficult for me to say at
this this stage whether we're going to
increase defense defense spending
because we don't know at this stage what
we're going to be inheriting when we
come into government would have to look
closely
um when we get closer to the election
what's in the coffers before we make a
decision as to whether to increase
spending but it is something that we'll
certainly review
um definitely as we get closer to the
election but the threat is something
that we are concerned about and looking
at how
um we can make sure that our country is
more secure
now we've got NATO defense ministers
meeting today would labor approve
sending fighter jets to Ukraine
I think this would be I think we need to
help make sure to see what the NATO what
comes out of NATO
um there needs to be
um a proper collaborative
um partnership work on this particularly
with NATO
um we have to see what comes out of this
meeting today to see what discussions
are put forward what proposals are first
they want to say that you know my
thoughts are with everybody in Ukraine
it's really sad that what I'm seeing
happening across um in Ukraine to
individuals that are being affected and
I think that UK has been a good Ally to
Ukraine so far and I think it's
important that we remain as as allies
but I also think it's really important
we see what comes out of the NATO
discussions before we we make a jerk um
reaction as to what should be should be
put forward
and certainly we may hear from nato in
terms of some sort of announcement later
today a banner upon a salary it's been
really good to have you with us thanks
so much for joining us